Elon Musk and Tech Titan sounding the
alarm on artificial intelligence over 1
000 liters pending a letter calling for
an immediate pause on new powerful AI
systems citing potential risks to
society the leaders warn that no one can
understand predict or reliably control
Ai and that the programs could spread
propaganda and make many jobs obsolete
new research finds that the technology
could impact 80 percent of the workforce
the CEO of the company behind chat gbt
recently warning how the powerful tool
will reshape Society
we've got to be cautious here I think
people should be happy that we're a
little bit scared of this I think people
should a little bit scared a little bit
you personally I think if I said I were
not you should either not trust me or be
very unhappy I'm in this job this will
be the the greatest technology Humanity
has yet developed
so Greg he's a little bit scared but he
didn't sign the letter well all AI is is
creating predictions based on the answer
key called life or Humanity right it
crowdsources all the stuff we've done
whether it's medicine or crime so
ultimately it would predict where your
cancer is and when it's going to come
and when and if you're going to get
mugged what street it will be it all
it's doing is it's pulling the curtain
behind the casino because all life is is
probability that's all it is that's what
our brain does every day we're always
trying to figure out what's going to
happen next he's right in the sense that
you need Humanity to interact with AI in
order to shape it if you don't have
Humanity dealing with it you won't find
the pluses or the minuses elon's right
to call it call a pause on it but for a
different reason AI isn't the enemy of
the people it's the enemy of the media
the media is the most destructive force
in our lives right now by monetizing
outrage it's taken every single uh story
in our lives and it finds the best way
to upset us right it's it's trying to
attract eyeballs through conflict AI
Done Right will present reality as
opposed to fake news so I made a list
would AI have pushed weapons of Master
destruction no would AI have called
riots mostly peaceful no would it called
Leah Thomas a woman no AI would not AI
would not cause a run on banks it would
have identified that one bank as an
anomaly we have mass shootings right AI
would know to pull back on coverage
based on statistics of probability so
every single problem in life can be
fixed with AI if you figure out the
right way to do Ai and then and
therefore it's the news media that
should be terrified without AI men are
women criminals are victims property
whether it's Goods or your home are up
for the taking these are toxic ideas
that flourish in our industry it's time
to change that and I think AI will do
that wow
I'm like I'm fascinated by what you're
saying because I don't understand it I'm
going to be honest with you I don't
understand it but it seems to me
whatever information is being fed into
it is the information it's going to spit
out okay so at first at first okay but
my this is my concern my concern is this
is about business all right so you're
dealing with businessmen there are they
competing with each other are they
competing with people from other
countries are there other competitors
out there is it are they going to Short
Circuit to get the most money in the end
or have the most control you know is
China involved is Russia involved I mean
all these problems are just raised to
another level and it kind of reminds me
of the internet the beginning of the
internet we were talking about the
communications decency act and how
should how should it be written I
remember I was working on the statute or
whether or not they would have liability
or are they a publisher or is it just an
open Forum I mean there's so many
questions that I don't know to ask but
what I do know is that it's going to
respond based upon what is fed into it
okay based on that do you think taking
this six month pause Jillian makes sense
yes but nobody's going to do it
um even the ones who signed the letter
correct because they're not ultimately
the ones who are going to need to make
that decision they're asking the
government to intervene and force all
other AI developers to take this pause
they're not voluntarily signing up to
take the call the pause there's not a
commitment built into the letter and for
that reason I think it's completely
disingenuous and I think the architects
of these AI programs that are leading
right now are fully aware of the fact
that this ship sailed years ago the
genie is way out of the bottle they're
like a day late in a dollar short
whatever any of those sayings are it
applies here I think this is these
executive China Curry favor with America
because they realize that they have
created the beginnings of this
technology that will one day control all
of human life and all of human behavior
and they don't want to be in the history
books as having created this monster
because at first as Greg did a good job
of laying out it spits out what is input
that's in the very infancy of AI
I mean 10 years from now not 10 weeks
won't matter one iota what we input is
recursive images today it literally
takes on a life of its own at some point
I'm not a conspiracy theorist this is a
great book book judge to read about AI
is the big nine I read it like a year or
two ago it is amazing it's about all the
big um the U.S and Chinese artificial
intelligence companies it's fantastic
and it really explains the lay of the
land Jesse what do you think most
Americans are worried about robots
taking their jobs here's why you
shouldn't worry about it robots can't be
consumed I'm already laughing robots
can't buy anything robots don't get
wages and they can't contribute to 401ks
robots can't be taxed you'd basically
destroy two-thirds of the economy
because two-thirds of the economy is
driven by consumer spending so you're
cannibalizing your entire Workforce no
businessman is going to do that and no
politician is going to allow to that
because it reduces economic activity it
also said that these things get so smart
they could make human slaves here's why
I'm not worried about that because
computers
are only motivated by efficiency
and slaves are not efficient if you look
at the southern economy versus the
northern economy oh my God the Southern
economy was incredibly inefficient it
was incredibly and if it was a backwards
economic model so they'll never go down
that road and why can't you just build a
kill switch or why can't you have fauchi
just invent a virus and give it to the
computer
lastly the thing I want to say I agree
with judge I have no idea what I'm
talking about
at some point you just have to let
Silicon Valley and deep State and Elon
Musk just decide everything and you know
what if they make me a slave I had a
good run yeah you did have a good run I
had a good run no I think they won't
make you a slave they'll just kill you
yeah see that's the economy still had a
good run no I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now